hotbox in this show why a show so so
important because it what it does is
it's it's putting a different different
spin or a different kind of face on
something that's been told taboo for so
long and I can't say enough about it so
like you know being on hot hot box with
Mike Tyson
you know is more than just just being
able to chat man we sit in a message
[Music]
another episode of I'm hotboxing here my
man Evan we're kicking ass today
you know how we got Rashad Evans hell
UFC classic yes sir what's up man what's
up it's a pleasure to be here man I got
first foremost I can't express to you
Mike enough you know how much your
career has impacted my life you know you
know from from an early age you know you
your fights is what brought my family
together you know really yeah yeah
absolutely man my father was your
biggest fan and um you know we actually
learned about fighting through watching
through watching you in the 80s and
stuff like that and you know I was I was
so into your style man I even you know
taught myself the peekaboo style and
yeah yeah I'm thinking New York great
yeah upstate New York that peekaboo
style a little bit yeah you know I
taught myself the motions and I watched
you know all Mike's training videos and
and I figured out you know like you know
which count would he do for which punch
and in his punch sequence and you know
the number system that he did and you
know I even um you know when I when I
got into my career I trained with this
guy named Billy white he says yeah yeah
so he had me doing some of the ain't no
no technique yeah some of the techniques
so you know you know it was something
that you know I just always dug Mike's
mentality you know cuz um you know he he
would he was honest about the way he
competed and I respected that meaning
the fact that you know he was he
he was transparent you know he was able
to feel you know feel fear but then
overcome it and as a fighter that's one
of the biggest that that is the fight
that that is the fight right there how
do you overcome you know your own
self-doubt in your own apprehension to
go out there and execute your technique
to flawless ability you know that's
that's the fight right there you know
and and I thought that Mike did a really
good job but just you know uh addressing
that and making sure that you know he
talked about it because him talking
about it made it easier for me as a
competitor to to be able to acknowledge
the fact that it's okay to feel fear
yeah to hear Mike talk about how every
fight he was he had fear he felt a ton
of fear throughout his boxing career and
how he overcame that and was never known
you know he's known as the most
ferocious dude to ever do it yeah you
know and so thinking back to my football
career man all the fear I felt before
games you know the fear of failing the
fear of getting being defeated you know
the fear of being embarrassed and having
to overcome that I think it's a natural
thing yeah you know it's what every
fighter every combat athlete you know
feels yeah every human being every
everybody do but it you know takes a an
honesty in yourself to be able to
acknowledge that because when you're in
a position especially as a fighter you
know you have this you know people have
this idea that you're fearless and and
and and fear and and you know you don't
feel any of those feelings but I you
know that that's that's part that for me
that was always the part of the the ride
which made me want to keep on keep on
fighting is the fact that every single
time that I fought I discovered a
different element of myself a different
element of who I was as a person and I
would you know overcome those doubts
those fears when I when when I go out
there and and you know go out there and
fight to my capabilities so you know
that was a you know it was huge
first and foremost to be like okay I can
be a badass fighter and still be be
afraid you just sometimes you know yeah
so that's the you know even to the fact
that like like Mike Mike has been such a
like a big part of my mindset when it
comes to a fighter I had someone do an
artist's composite of Mike's Mike's eyes
you know because the thing whenever I
see Mike compete and and I seen you know
when you know I'm able to judge Mike was
gonna go out there and catch Frank
I always seen it in his eyes you know
I'm saying he always had this look in
his eyes where you know it was just you
know he was going to go and do his thing
and you know when when I wanted the
picture I'm like you know let me just
get let me just get Mike's eyes so I
could just see you know and that's and
that's what I got on the wall at my
house man just just your eyes man just
because I'm like you know this this is
the foundation of of me being able to do
what I was able to do just being able to
be like you know to recognize I focus on
like this is the kind of focus this is
the kind of intensity I got to have when
I go out there I gotta want to be able
to to devour my opponent and face the
fear and face all those feelings and go
out there and catch rack you know that
self is hell dude yeah man that's love
that yes is you know that's that's
that's what I had to say you know for
Mike mantis oh yeah bro so listen and
tell me Mike sorry if you meet any J's
there in there brother
no dude we got that bird cage bro okay
okay I'm good right now man
thank you yes Mike gave one of these to
Joe Rogan oh man I still was I I seen em
I've seen a podcast Mike yeah I was uh I
was impressed man just because of um you
know I like I like the mentality and
where you headed as far as like your
self-discovery on you know the deeper
side of life you know I'm saying like
the other side of life that that
no one really talks about you know like
the spiritual side of life you know I'm
saying because I myself took that same
trip that you did with with the toad I'm
told it's incredible yeah yeah I did the
times Oh incredible it's awesome dude
what was your experience with the toad
man it was when it came to me it was you
know a buddy of mine isn't it his name
is Dale out in out in Colorado you know
I was I was kind of going through some
changes where I just wanted to you know
just just find out like what life was
truly about because I started to see
that the system I started to see the
system as a system I started to see that
the matrix of thought you know I'm
saying the matrix of the paradigm in
which we live in in which we call our
reality right so I was kind of getting
to the point where I was at my breaking
point and I needed something and I
posted I posted something and then by it
my post that I made he was like you know
Rashad I think I have something for you
so you know after my last fight it
didn't go my way and you know I was kind
of still searching because you know I
was like man I gave everything I had and
I couldn't believe that my career was
gonna end and in a way that that I just
never foreseen you know I always felt
like I had more left but you know I just
I just fell short when it comes to
desire when it comes to meeting that
intensity I just didn't have it anymore
you know and I had to be honest with
myself so that that face in that truth
was was really really hard for me and it
was something that put me into a hard
mental state so when the opportunity
came and he told me about this retreat
that he was having in Colorado you know
I had to I had to jump all over it
and you know it was something that I did
a lot of research on before but it was
something that I felt like I really
needed to do and and when I did it it
changed my life man because you know
when when you when you take that that
that medicine and you go to that place
where you you leave your body you know
and you stop
the part of you that you have become
that you know as yourself it dies and
you have and you face what you've always
feared your whole life which is you
coming to an end
and then you realize once you come to an
end that that was just the beginning of
existence and there's a whole set of a
whole nother existence outside of that
and then you start to understand that
you're you're you're you're part of
something that's so enormous lessly
massive that is almost incomprehensible
to your waking mind in this in this
reality you know what I'm saying and
when you when you when you come back
into your body you you feel kind of like
reality starts to come back together
again
and then you start to to understand that
you know you're a human being and you
have what you yeah yeah I do I was
crying I was crying when I came back I
didn't want to come back yeah I know
when I say that people say what they
want to come back I want to stay dead
yeah I thought I'd died I wanted to stay
that way
but did you did you feel did you feel
like the UH like the the the the gold
like I was I felt like I was in and I
felt like I was inside of the Sun listen
there's no I didn't want to come back
here I knew I didn't want to come back
here when the time came and um
it warf I was like what the [ __ ]
happened what did you do [ __ ] I
was angry
yeah somebody took something ugly and do
and I didn't want to come back I said
put me under again I wouldn't under
again did you go back under again the
most the most amazing part for me was
once I got into that state of being
where I come out of myself I felt like I
was every single thing in existence all
at the same time and and and what kind
of you know what kind of what kind of
brought me a little bit of pause was
because when I was gone I didn't miss
anybody I didn't miss anything I didn't
have that
feeling of that I thought I would have
once I leave this earth but the truth
about it is once I started to examine
that understanding deeper I got to
understand the reason why I didn't miss
anybody or miss anything is because
every single thing that was I I thought
was outside of me was actually inside of
me like all the people that I've know
you know you it this reality is all a
part of my inside it's not so much of a
reflection of the outside you know I'm
saying so I was afraid I was afraid
you'd think that was afraid if you feel
that family I was afraid of losing my
children and I was just afraid and you
hear that you hear to say you hear the
sound you hear the music calling you
more and more deeper and man I'm I've
never felt that feeling before freedom I
can't even say freedom I have a
different perception of freedom and
freedom is not what I yeah exactly
not none let me ask you general face you
know because I this is what I picture
freedom feel yeah its existence to me
it's reality to me this is freedom i
hitted me to be able to do what I want
legally to do what I want this just took
me to another level beyond that did you
did you feel the the pull of the all
like like um like what I felt as if like
I felt as if and it was and it was and
it was the thing was like there was no
mistaken the understanding it was like
as if like once I was there I was
instantly being downloaded with true
with with the true realities of it with
the true reality of existence and and
from that true reality of existence you
know I was able to put it you know to to
feel that you know all of the existence
is part of one collective conscience and
that's all what we share and the fact
that when we have these personal
experiences were actually if we were to
look at ourselves as an entity will be
probably one big entity that has an
existence in and has individual I guess
experiences through each of our egos
right so so like when we when we do that
we move and our egos completely gone
and and and and like for me like when I
got like when I got done I it was kind
of confusing because for me it was like
I did all of that to realize that in in
essence I truly don't exist in in the
sense of in a sense of individuality
like like I'm Rashad Evans but that's
the name my mother gave me you know my
perception and would the way people
think of me these are things that you
know our based on the character in which
they describe me on which they you know
the title in which they know me right
you know as a father they look at me one
way as a son and look at me another way
as an athlete they look at me another
way and and as a friend it looks me at
another way but all those things are not
me individually right so there there's a
there's a higher form of me that exists
and once I you know once I get past the
ego of who I think I am then you can get
down to what truly is and it's and it's
kind of amazing to be honest this is
what the [ __ ] we do here yes this is
what we do bro everything my experience
is welcome
I missed it but I didn't exist you know
you dear you exist you're not in your
body your body doesn't exist it's just
man no no let me ask you like when I
came back and once I started to
conceptualize like life and and and and
and what it all meant you know looking
at reality and in the way that we live
our life it just became so so so fake to
me to the point where I had a hard time
making an adjustment at first and trying
to put things in his proper perspective
because I realized that you know a lot
of things that I thought were so
important were really it was really not
important at all and and and the fact of
the the system in which we we live and
in died for and we dream for and we we
you know base our whole existence off of
is nothing more than a system incomplete
based off the fact that it doesn't
address the nature of what we truly are
you know because it's it's selling us
something that
truly not what we are we're so much more
than than what we've been told you know
and I think that's what you disconnect
absolutely I just feel that a
disconnection you know what the total
gave me a disconnection of what I really
what I believed all my life you know
that everything I believed all my life
was a lie yeah you know yeah it's all a
lie was touring believed all my life was
a lie it's just made up that's let's see
that's that's that's the heartbreaking
part about it like you get left at a
state that you don't know yeah that's
[Music]
like what am i what do I really know
well I I really don't know nothing I
think the silver lining in all of the
fact that that the I guess the when the
world ceased to exist because that's the
only way I can I can say it best is the
fact that once you discover the truth
about the world it sees to it ceased to
be real to you right and then you enter
a state where you know you have this
void I guess where you really understand
where you are but I think like for me
the best part is I got to reconstruct my
idea of what I want my reality to be you
know I'm saying how much importance I'm
going to put on you know the the
monetary things in life and and trying
to get ahead versus you know living with
the real aspects of life and and and and
I do and for me like I like to dissolve
my ego as much as possible so I like to
do psychedelics you know I'm saying
because that allows me to you know get
past this ego that sometimes gets in a
way of proper human interaction this
does it what do you call your what do
you call a plant-based stuff tonight
then plant medicine TDM - yeah you then
dnt yes that's right that's more fun
yeah fun yeah
the tow doesn't walk the TARDIS
yeah the duh the tote is gonna tell you
something about existence in general and
I think like the the the plant the
spirit molecule tells you more about you
know I guess your your your souls
progression through this existence you
know it'll give you somewhere it'll give
you some kind of like some some
scattered like ayahuasca no I I want to
do I want to do ayahuasca I want to do
ayahuasca but what I wanted so so for
like this past year man like I just been
it's like I just I just been going
through some changes man I've been going
through some change it's like I used to
be a heavy drinker I used to be a heavy
partier and stuff like that but then as
I started to do things to dissolve my
ego you know I had different experiences
where it's kind of weaned me off of like
doing doing those kind of stuff so like
I don't I don't I don't
I no longer have the urge to drink any
alcohol at all anymore like I just don't
drink it anymore you know and then you
know and something weird happened to me
as far as like eating meat you know
before I used to like to eat meat but
then you know as I did a couple
psychedelics like I did I had to trip on
time and you know sometimes the mushroom
talks to you in it and and it it like I
have a theory based on why the mushroom
talks to you because it kind of came to
me in a deep trip one time and yeah so
here's here's why I came to kind of come
to understand why the psychedelics in
the mushroom is able to bring you this
kind of knowingness that that you you
can't really explain so so if you think
about you know the oldest the oldest
beings here on this planet you have to
look at vegetation right you have to
look at the plant system and in the
trees and things like that and that's
something we really don't give enough
credit for is their intelligence and
their ability to you know be able to
survive you know so there there's some
kind of intelligence that these plants
have to be able to survive like for
instance if they communicate through the
root system you know if if we were to
put the plants in an anatomical scale
like you do a human you know their their
legs would be sticking up those would be
the two
the tree as we see but their brains
would be the roots that's underneath and
those those roots are our what they're
using to pass information all along so
they have a network of communication
where they're constantly passing
information like for instance if if a
tree is getting attacked by some kind of
insects or something like that it is
send a chemical off and then it passed
information and then all the other trees
will understand that they need to make
some kind of defense for so then they
release a chemical that gives the animal
or right away so they ask you and think
this is all coming in this trip yeah yes
I've had this theory myself yes yes I'm
so I'm coming with this understanding
and you know the trip told me to sit
down and they said how do you expect to
understand anything that's like above
you if you don't understand what's below
your feet and it was below my feet was
just as network of understanding like
this this complete network of
communication is library of knowledge of
the planet so as I as I as I understood
you know mycelium mushrooms are one of
the most intricate parts of of the
system and you know the the networking
system you know they they link all these
these these trees and these plants all
of them are linked together so they all
communicate with each other so I believe
that there's knowledge that that's in
the root system of the mycelium right so
when you eat it it causes you to have
these downloads of some of that
information so it's like like for
instance there there there's a mycelium
that makes this ant eats the mice ant or
insect eat them I see them and then it
climbs to the highest point like a tree
or a roof and then it dies and it
explodes and then the spores come out of
the head of the ant so therefore these
mycelium act that never did the toad I
was [ __ ] toes yeah it's true yeah so
I I believe that when when when we eat
the mushroom
it gives us the download of what is
going on with the earth with with what's
going on around
what's going on with the ether and where
and when we're able to tap into that
then we have different understanding of
the place that we live in it and I think
honestly speaking the reason why the
world is in a place that it is it's
because we don't do enough mushrooms do
you know Paul Stamets have you ever -
yeah yeah listen to Paul this is what he
talks about yeah you know that yes yes
Paul's a genius man yeah I follow him on
a Joe Rogan showing that and that's good
you know that's what made me start
becoming you know Joe Rogan show was one
of those shows that that kind of started
- oh my gosh no and and to look at
things a little bit deeper you know and
you know there there are some things
that you know that that bring a lot of
controversy that they talk about but
they're absolutely correct about I feel
yeah absolutely
it's a mic I'm out there Michael ma yeah
this is what we're all about now so
how's your uh I mean you like you like
weed cannabis is something you use did
you use it as a fighter not not to the
end man but it was something that you
know once I discovered it it saved me
because you know like I was telling Mike
in the green room you know when you when
you fight it's the recovery part is the
hardest part to be able to to get by
because you know when MMA there's so
many different facets of the sport you
know we have to be able to hit all those
different disciplines to be to be
efficient and be fluid and and not have
any you know and not any tells them in
any one discipline that's for them next
so you have to make you know time to do
all these different disciplines so you
you have to be able to rinse and repeat
and how many times can you do that over
and over and over again and that that
becomes the tell of how fast you can
grow in the sport you know and when
you're not able to recover and feel
rested then you're only able to maybe
get in a couple of different deaths of
disciplines in and and you're not
growing you're not progressing you know
like like that's that's why that's why a
lot of these the younger fighters are
able to move so far ahead of these older
guys because they have the energy to
keep on going and go on and do work
don't work out because their
testosterone is higher I will work out
four times a day all day really it's
working all day and then and then I look
after I've been [ __ ] my girlfriend
get a pump like oh I gotta get right
pump oh oh that's that that was me man I
would I would work out four times a day
and then he'd McDonald's you know I'm
saying if you you know my my you know
you know I'll leave right I'll leave it
alone I'll leave then I'll leave I'll
leave was a long side with me and them
and that's what we're doing you know we
eat garbage food and we're going with
train like maniacs
my train is to hate this and listen I
want steak tonight okay I go to Burger
King and something of steak tonight okay
might I do anavar for how would you feel
good right oh yeah that's all right
eight steaks and lobster stuffed
actinium 20 years old like I you know
I've really taken some time since I
stopped fighting to to properly
understand nutrition the right way you
know saying I learned a lot of stuff
about you know doctor say be and then it
works that he does and stuff like that
yeah I would be blown away always a
snicker and drink yeah but that's
despite that despite that the sugar says
sugar spiked the sugar spiked tell us a
little bit about doctor seve
yeah so doctor savvy man he was quite
amazing you know he is you know he's
he's a holistic doctor who really caught
a lot of flack because he took on a
medical industry in a way that has never
been done before and he was able to
actually win a case against the medical
industry saying that he was able to cure
diseases that the medical industry can't
cure like cancer and AIDS and in
hepatitis and and all these these
different diseases and he's able to do
that because his philosophy on nutrition
is about you know eating electric food
and getting rid of a lot of the food
that we have become to know as food and
and get rid of eating animal food and
plant base very very plant base but more
or less you know an electric diet so you
know he's more like Antwoord more yeah
electric because here's a reality we you
know we're carbon-based life-forms but
we you know we use electrical impulses
in order for our body to communicate you
know and in the simple fact that we use
we have an acid based diet which slows
down the electrical impulses for our
body to communicate efficiently then
then we're actually really you know I
guess you know short in our capacity of
what we can do as human beings yeah
you know because we cuz when you're able
to physically you know have have one in
your body communicate properly to the
other then then you get rid of things
like strokes and and bad circulations
and things like that that causes problem
at old age you know you don't get the
plaques in your brains and things having
a lot of surgery prevents your body from
communicating yeah because because you
know a lot of the medicine in the
pharmaceutical industry is not it's not
bioavailable to your body meaning the
fact that your body can't break it down
you know so then it ended up going into
different areas of your bodies and
different glands that get stuck and it
makes it so that you you know you you
have a toxic level of a chemical that
your body can't do anything with but
cause you know a disease so it's you
know it's it's it's a touchy it's a
touchy thing man because we're being
poisoned I don't know if it's
intentional or a poison sometimes yeah
dude I don't I don't think anything is
by accident I think that uh they want to
get us out of here there's there's more
there's more to population control
there's more outta system and that's and
that's and that's necessary
unfortunately cuz it makes it really
hard to be to be an American and to be
and to be proud of being an American
because the truth of the matter is you
know there's there's a lot of dissension
in America based off of the fact that
you know people ideas of what it is to
be an American it is not in line with
each other but if you look at what we
say
and by the pledge of allegiance in our
vow that whenever we you know sing sing
our National Anthem those are the vowels
that we have deviated from you know and
the truth of the matter is you know a
lot of a lot of black people and a lot
of people who were Colin Kaepernick you
know stopped standing up just because
when when at what point do we start
holding our country accountable to - to
what we're saying you don't know saying
like I get that you know it's really a
hard and complex problem that really has
to be handled with with a delicate care
but at the same time you know I think
that if we force our you know our
resources are in our mentality to really
solve this problem they're something
that can be solved but you know then
again you have to understand that we're
in a system that that is created to to
cut us off from from what what is most
important which is understanding that
we're a lot more connected than we are
separate and and and that mentality and
that understanding of human interaction
can change the world but that's not one
that's pushed you know selfishness and
everything else is what's when you're
writing your book dude [ __ ] book man
god [ __ ] dude that's why these
medicines are emerging I believe that's
why mushroom psilocybin and LSD and DMT
in ayahuasca all these things are and
cannabis you know because the earth Gaia
the spirit of this thing that we are all
connected to is saying guys you need to
wake the [ __ ] you know that because I
mean that's that's the only way
honestly that we're going to be able to
to make it so that that our children are
able to have a life and their children
share able to have a life and I think
that you know we owe it to existence in
general to make sure that it goes on and
it carries on and that you know whatever
this is that we're a part of that that
we we get to really live it to its
fullest potential because at the end of
the day
it shouldn't just be about how many cars
you can have or all the things that you
can you can buy monetarily you know I
thought I think that existence has
gotten away from that your waste from
her yeah it's gotten away from heart
it's got the energy to yeah it's got
it's gotten away from human interaction
you know I'm saying it's gotten away
from all that and I think that it
doesn't it doesn't progress or go any
further if it continues to move at this
rate you know this prevents human to
actuate right yeah take you like you
don't even talk to me on the phone yeah
yeah that's that's the thing and that's
the thing you know I'm a parent too and
as a parent you know that's that's how
it is like you know trying to being able
to communicate with your kid is it gets
difficult and it gets to be like
something that you as a parent have to
constantly constantly check yourself and
be like you know what I can be doing
better in this area because it's easy as
a parent to kind of to kind of take -
yeah it's easy to slip away to allow it
to slip away and allow it to get out of
hand and then next thing you know you're
looking up when your kids making bad
decisions like how did we get here you
know I'm saying but you know it's a
joint after yeah it's a joint effort but
it's recognizing when as a parent like
how do we like when do I need to you
know strap down a little bit as a parent
you know yeah for sure
but it helped me kids you have I have
four I have four kids how old I got one
that's 19 and yeah then my youngest is
is three years old but I got a in the
middle of a 12 and a 10 year old and
amazing yeah it's amazing but you know
you know my life is uh it's been
difficult because you know I had you
know I had a situation where you know
where I had I had you know relationships
and I had children I had a different
situation like I had my first kid when I
was you know a young one 19 years old
myself and then I got married and then I
had two with my wife and then I got
divorced and then I have my last one so
you know it's just a story of my life
but at the same times it it you know has
prevented a percentage of problem as as
a parent because it's hard to be ever
it's hard to be able to pursue a life
where you want to you know give them the
better things and you know chase a dream
but at the same time you still need to
be I wish I have more kids
yeah a toejam or see that's that's yeah
I want more kids to finish go say more I
want more kids
I've won I I do outdoor buy so this is
so many different with different
personalities or you yeah damn that me
mine is whacked out that's the amazing
part is like you know when these kids
start expressing different interests you
know like like I had my son little
Rashad man he's uh he's so different and
dynamic in his own way because you know
he's he's very strong on not being not
being me you know he doesn't he's very
conscious you know he's like you know he
wants to stay on his own and he's into
comedy man he did his first little
comedy is comedy look at six minutes man
12 yeah man so I was just blown away
yeah but he's just he just got that
personality then you know I got you know
hit the one has his sister the 10 year
old she's uh she's um she's she's so
funny because she's she's like the most
caring and sweetest of all of them you
know I'm saying she's just like she's
just so considerate you know and such a
team player and honestly speaking she's
she's kind of like the rough is one like
we're not like when it comes to fighting
she wants to know she wants to learn the
most about fighters oh that's cool yeah
my daughter's in karate dude I'm stoked
he loves it I'm like [ __ ] yeah dude seth
has an awesome keep it going yeah man
you know it's amazing man you know
and being a young parent and having
having a kid who was 19 is is is it's
challenging you know because sure you
know when she was machine was 16 years
old she ended up telling me she's like
dad I wanna I wanna have sex when it
when I'm six this you know I'm gonna
have sex this year in all the sixteen
and and I'm like I'm I'm trying you know
because she's very open and honest with
me you know I'm sample I look great
she said that mirror and and it kind of
made me mad a bit but then when you know
she was like you know she's like whoa
well you had me when you were 19 and not
and I really you know I really didn't
have an answer for that but uh you know
I just I just let her know as much as I
can how much I trusted her to make the
right decision based on you know being
smart and not just doing something just
to do it you know so great great advice
but yeah that would that was hard though
man yeah yeah I am NOT looking forward
to my daughter being a teenage Oh my
daughter was a trip it's crazy right and
um I'm just savoring this thing you know
she's kind of you know she's big what no
room that girls take no [ __ ] that's
awesome I mean that's a good thing I
think it's good it's good to see that
and for me like you know it is so good
to see you know them coming into their
own and and and becoming you know a
little little you know people you know
what I'm saying and and and and it's
always interesting as a parent when you
see you know your child start breaking
away from you and becoming their own
their own person you know because you
know part of you just I don't like that
part that's the heart that's the
heartbreaking part because it's like
it's like first grade felt like ah yeah
taking her to first grade I know listen
um you really get with you take them to
college then they got their own month in
that school education to think a certain
way and they
the way that you don't even communicate
yeah yeah who's this person who told you
to think like there who's even talking
to yeah I know you know yeah that's
that's that's that's the hard part on
that plate because like in the world
next yeah take him to an anger stay with
these morals and just kinda it's just
crazy
yeah well when when when when they first
started - yeah and then and then as and
then like it's something weird happens
like when you're when your daughter
starts to you know you know the intimate
or start that way to want to be intimate
with a guy it's almost like she has to
you know just like take you ad out of
the helm of being that guy in her life
so she kind of she almost gives
lightweight kind of you know
disrespectful and kind of tries you a
bit but it's just that's untried yeah
that's the guard okay I'ma be who wear
one of these that's the part as a father
we just kind of kind of be like yeah I'm
trying I'm gonna try not to cuss him out
you know you try to be understanding
that's why I'm lifting weights man the
whole way you guys gonna come out foot
come out with [ __ ] sleeveless shirt
yeah out of the basement after pumping
iron mm-hmm what's up [ __ ] yeah
who are you here to see not sandy let's
go to rain I said listen check this out
right what do we do the Hama do to you
yeah hey that's enough to make you
behave right there that's a crazy visual
man oh yeah let me rethink that man
Mendota freak get away from her giving
you a no it's get away but I think if I
get away that's what she said to you
yeah a get away but but I mean like I
mean like what the guys think when he
like come to your house and like thank
God yes sir first thing yes sir they
tried it my daughter try to avoid me
seeing them know who they are they know
party
party the house and the guys in the
point we don't know he is the mother
explains this the guys know and
sometimes you're gonna be surprised
sometimes it might be a Caucasian yeah
yeah I think what do you see in him
yeah you'll see intimate like your
father yeah yeah but I'll be I mean
because I gotta be it's gotta be weird
for them because you know for me for me
like like just notice you from the
outside I know I know that you're the
kind of person that you know if you feel
any kind of disrespect in any kind of
way or even if even if you feel like the
tone was even going to kind of way where
you feel tried you're not afraid to set
somebody straight I'll think I won't
hate to do it yeah but we do it I'm
gonna put an example down for my child
whoever made that it's lovely to stay
dating I'm gonna put it down and let
your father do yeah you know they never
seen that side of me and it always
bossed me around and stuff yeah yeah so
they never seen that side of me I think
I'm really the would talk dorky guy cuz
I'm sorry bear
yeah I'll say none to my let them take
advantage yeah but I was thinking about
that I'll decide yeah I mean that would
have to be a difficult situation man
because my god I will hate to have one
who's got to put their hands on their
girlfriends and stuff yeah yeah yeah
that lady I'll put your demonstration
down yeah you have you have to you have
to demonstration down for your daughter
yeah at that point demonstration the
demonstration I like the way you say
that - cause it sounds it sounds so
official like yeah yeah that that needs
to happen you know yeah a demonstration
I'm sorry but but have you ever got to
the point where year actually ever felt
like that it may have to go down like
that like have you ever been to a point
we like you know what he might need to
be corrected dig
my daughter oldest girl indeed she dated
this um basketball guiding this guy
talked to slick and I knew this guy
wasn't gonna be good she wasn't ready to
date no guy he was talking slick like
pressure busts pipes I can handle
presently get the basketball play at
something and answers in that situation
right there I'm II had um I don't know
deal with him so to speak yeah I mean if
one day he was playing basketball he had
a bunch of little girls waiting at the
basketball and my daughter's waiting for
him to you know me and my daughter never
confronted she's not that kind of person
and stuff but I let her know these are
the kind of guys you're gonna get them
in trouble you know like a guy you got
taken with his faults and everything
because if you like the guy and he hurt
you like this you're giving a lot of
trouble and then your father might be in
a lot of trouble
and I expect you to come see me when I'm
in prison yeah see see now that there's
this II like like like like that last a
little bit right there it is you're
saying a lot without saying anything at
all and I expect you to come to see me
in prison you know that's like said hey
I will go through the limit for this you
don't upset
that's deep Mike that's deep man
hey so Mike let me ask you man um you
know I'm a big fan of underground scene
and I know you you from Brownsville yeah
and um you know which you know about the
50 to the 52 blocks
man that's been going on prize seven
yeah yeah man yeah so uh so I might be
working on this project man but the 52
man yeah yeah so I thought I want to get
I want to get some of your info so so
tell me so tell me a little bit about
the history of it man how you come
across it
this is the real deal right yes here you
hear about the kick I was doing an
imprint of then you hear about this guy
named what was his name mother did this
homosexual god I used to rape people put
that's just oh that's just um the
history yeah
yeah and he was the best yeah he was the
best practitioner figure in prison yeah
yeah man history um almost at you but he
was a vicious merciless fighter damn man
yeah I know that I know that style
because I seen I've seen a couple
elements of uh of it when you when you
fought I figured uh who wasn't used to
fighting man it was a dang I forget who
it was but you you you went on the
inside with it and you moved you Bob the
within you and you got to the inside
with it and they came up with a left
hook off of it let's just have it yeah
yeah yeah that's but those guys they're
guys in Brooklyn eatin that's them after
that there's kids they could do it
brilliant man make me look like an
amateur
so so with the Picabo style like like
once you got to cus how hard was that
for you to master because it looked as
if very complex yeah it's very complex
right it's almost like being a turtle
hands up chin down boom you know it's
almost like karate move not coming it's
back move you guys always move gotta
move move
and I'm moving and keeps your hands but
you're doing your chin down your hand
buddy Joe underneath your cheekbone so
you can see the punches still yes yeah
so it's like repetition repetition over
and over and over again they make the
numberless system down throwing the
punch two three four four five things
you gotta get it there you know the
punches though it's real complex but
it's really simple so you know and and
and and that's then I was a beauty you
started I was dug because a lot of
people you know that they kind of missed
they kind of missed dubbed you fighting
style is more of a brawling style but
they they missed they missed a mastery
in it you know I'm saying like you were
able to box within that style you know a
lot of times that you were able to out
jab people okay reach you know I'm
timing - yeah bit about timing so that's
that's that's what I that's what I dug
most about the style and it's like you
know once you came when she came with
that jab you know you you had
you got different kind of jabs you do
sometimes you got the jab where you just
kind of you you leave it out there you
leave it out there kind of long and then
you got one where you kind of you know
you get behind it moving and you pump it
come aside aside and you rip whatever
side you coming out on that is how much
I was watching the style what part of
the need for we from Rochester Buffalo
yeah yeah we changed every times from up
there yeah hang with but listen one day
when I was younger be way before I met
real great I used to date this girl
fleeced in Buffalo but she was a model
in New York and so I went to Buffalo
there's a family and I said let's go Vic
team so she said no we're not going to
Rick James house oh man Wow big part was
doing drugs when I was like 19 at the
time I was clean-cut
before I started listen Vic was the best
man Rick James is the best you live by
the fruit belt yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
man but Mike man in your time man you
you uh and nineteen man you was thrown
to the world man and that's crazy right
it's crazy to me because like you know
Mike Mike has been mike has been through
it all man and to be able to come out
and beat this guy right now you know I'm
saying us that's a true testament of
just a mindset and internal fortitude
that it takes you know saying like
that's that's that's my I was lucky I
didn't die dough so I was really looking
at and doctor I got input in so many
situations over the years I should have
been dead
I see the old deed somebody should have
killed me bhai how did how did you how
did you handle dealing with donek a man
I've met Don can comfort I listen at 80
something years old
[Music]
Don King don't forget [ __ ] Don King that
Kings always like that [ __ ] I
still owe me money he remembers
everything man I was I was impressed by
that man I wasn't oh my nose everybody
money'll says somebody out here muddy
but Don amazing shitty cuz he's still in
Florida he still got a building down
there with his name on it I'm nobody's
in the book yeah no fighters
that's so funny yeah man but though so
so what do you think of a boxing game
right now I mean I think I think is that
an interesting point right now man if
interest in the why because we have some
new fighters coming up yeah but what we
have to do now is get those fighters out
there in the mainstream you know I'm a
graphic arrows fencing javante Davis and
those guys and the llama [ __ ] holes in
those guys we gotta get those guys
mainstream you know to me I mean I think
tank was pretty pretty mainstream but I
think he's still needed competition yeah
that's that's the problem he's missing
he missing an adversary yeah like this
to Vontae Davis guys really good but
he's gonna need another year and a half
to be in that level right right what do
you think about what you think about
Tyrone Spong
Tyrone doing Harrell doing good man he
just uh you know he wants to rock huh
yeah he's doing it man I think he's like
number seven number eight in the world
when a heavyweight not had a heavyweight
be so awesome yeah he's looking like me
he fell from ork and then hey with now
so [ __ ] big right yeah yeah so yeah
so we're like what was your biggest
advantage being a smaller guy because
you you you I mean you was like well
attracted so fast yeah I had a good
defense and I was really ferocious to me
when I when I was I'm aggressive that's
the key right there that's the key right
there because yeah he's not I mean I
mean you know you always have to let
people know they can't afford to make a
mistake that's it that's don't make a
[ __ ] mistake in but and by being
enough state
mine you're gonna make mistakes because
there now you're afraid you make the
mistake here that's what's up man so
Rashad I've heard you have a good mic
invitation yeah I got a good mic I
didn't want to break it out cuz I won't
might I won't like this wake up this is
this this is so I don't know if you
remember this man I met you once I met
you I met you one time when when we was
at a club was at Dre's one time it goes
right out there it was right after I
fought Machida and you come up to me and
he was like he was like I was like Oh
Mike what's up man nice to meet you he
is that yeah yeah nice nice nice to meet
you as well
and I was like I was like and I was like
Mike and he was like yeah I saw your
last fight and I was like yeah and he's
like yeah first of all you know III seen
you had a lot of fear in your heart and
it feels like fire because coz coz coz
left unmanaged you know fear fear fear
and fear if you can do some terrible
things but but but but left harness
harness the right way for you can do
some beautiful things and you can't let
fear get in your heart like that and I
was like man like that's that's pretty
deep man you know it but but but you
know saying I was surprised that Mike I
was surprised that Mike was dropping
like he's drunk I met your family
assistance yeah you told me our wife is
so hot she's run to the ring the
checklist right there that's why ya was
your wife a nurse assistant yeah I used
to love Mike when he get up there like
I'm the greatest father guards ever
created like oh yeah first of all Mike
was there like I was like yes he is
married yeah like like no young you
crazy doesn't say that
it's in your heart your heart you gotta
say that rage mi mentum had me wanting
to kill people I couldn't control it in
their gym I would knock these guy that I
always keep in yeah yeah yeah I used to
look that's I used to love to watch his
sparring matches because you wouldn't
wear a headgear and and and you you was
like you would go for you go get a lot
less going on yes born here go for it
like I guess I'm used to telling got
first thing to hey listen I know he's a
kid but do your best don't take it easy
with him do your best okay I'm being
sincere with you
all right I'm letting you know glue your
back you do your best don't look at him
as a kid do your best
that wasn't my hands on them back then
you know yeah see see what was so for me
like my thing was like what was my thing
that made me fight was you know I had a
hard upbringing so that was my that was
my fuel you and I'm saying like I had a
lot of resentment you know for my father
at one point because you know I felt as
if like you know once I once I got to a
certain age you know we fell out of
communication so I kind of carried that
resentment and that was my fuel you know
what I'm saying but as um you know that
fuel would would make me fight like an
animal I can just tap into it at any
given time like I could just close my
eyes and I can just like tap into that
mindset you know but it's like as as I
got older and and as I started to live
life and and start to you know see life
differently you know I'm saying start
making some of the same mistakes that
you know my father made I started to
feel different about that situation if I
feel different about my father and I
slowly started to forgive him over time
and as I started forgiving my father and
start forgiving different aspects of my
life that that that that rage and fuel
are you safe for fighting it started to
go man it to the point where I just I
just I just became so much at peace you
know and it was like I remember that
they liked that that passenger went away
man it was
you know I just I just when I tried to
hit it one time at a fight and it was
just like it didn't flare up you know
you know like in my situation it wasn't
about money when about my up and I
wanted to be these guys mm-hmm I wanted
to be our Lea one to be [ __ ] the rant
I want to be sugary I wanted to be them
yeah I was envious I wanted to be them I
was jealous of them yeah yeah I didn't
know what the [ __ ] I was gonna do and I
get it but I wanted to be them yeah yeah
I like that man I like that man that's
that's a that's a ever few of the
mindset you know they can keep on going
and keep on going man but it's you know
what it is however hero-worship yeah
it's a penis it's all it's about
I would do anything yeah go for ya it's
about the story you tell yourself why
you compete you don't know saying it and
and and when you achieve something you
know like when you become champion like
God did like you did like when you were
younger you look they can do anything
there and bother nobody [ __ ] with
everybody loves to my dad a father
looking with all that money and Julie
welcomed by himself that he oh ever they
want yeah
no way we're dead [ __ ] who's your
favorite who's your favorite Mike Connor
all of like all the other champions who
was your favorite man
I like Duran Duran him and I leave I
wasn't as fair I wasn't in an era but
listen he was a month this guy had like
um nobody had he had um he had 45:31 all
in the road and xli funny loss right
then he 193 in a row after that god damn
and I need three in a row now and I'm
and I love his fighting style the weight
like like the way he threw punches back
then like he let the [ __ ] go way
back here but it always found it's like
at 127 fights with one loss man
you know in this day and age this is
where the Warriors go you know to these
sports or to the military you know a
thousand years ago you know we we might
have been Spartans you know we were
warriors and another life I like that um
from fighting was like life that you can
keep going keep going giving your best
and things you get a disappointment you
might lose but continue to go on act
like it didn't come that and continue go
never let it break your your confidence
your will it succeed
you know losses can't be taking this
death sentences some people take a loss
a their death sent their you can't now
absolutely man that's that's that's
that's deep right there because a lot of
Fighters man you like they date they
identify themselves so strongly on the
fact that they can't lose and then when
they lose they they they're the left
with you know we with such an identity
shattering you know problem that they
they fail to make the adjustment so they
can improve to redeem that long those
guys you see like Robinson hourly you
see what they do when they come back
from my boss you see I they fight they
ready listen it quite like oddly like
when he was the old guy he is no
quitting I'm it's like a pig the pitbull
you gotta kill him the beat oh yeah you
know he's not going to give up like when
he was older and he was on a rope you
get beat up a home quit quit that's
that's incredible man that's awesome
that's a different will and different
mindset man the kind of punishment that
he was able to take in
gosh man is that doesn't does a
different kind of mentality man you
don't up saying like then beat your ass
yeah man yeah you know we'll have to
learn for my you know adversities in
life you know yeah yeah yeah it's just
that's like fight now it is one thing
you have to know that's one thing is
finally you have to remember why
thing forget everything else you were
left hook your right hand you're going
to go 15 rounds I'm knocking them out
you're going 15 rounds away he'd listen
he'll let you go and listen him move it
down a little bit ten foot ten around
twelve thirteen
then he's gonna fight you like an animal
for the next three or four rounds
usually justice he's gonna start lacing
you yeah he's gonna start lately coming
from this punches are coming from
knowing boom hard Oh wearing these big
Giants down yeah in the fifteenth round
he still pump pop boom boom see that the
guys to fight a still one afraid you
still wants to coming really beat
Australia if it can't go no more yes
done can't go no more see that's that's
that's the legendary stinkin beat him
but he still wanted to get it and I used
to love Frazier I love did your style
afraid to it's a month his style you
know you know Bert Watson used to tell
me that afraid you had that style
because he his vision was messed up so
he couldn't see so he always wanted to
fight like that just so that what he can
always feel somebody's breath on top of
oh you can't see no more but it's it's
nuts men like that that is a like like
you're part of that legacy man and
that's and that's amazing to me because
it's like you you're such a living
legend like you you can you can easily
be named in that number one spot you
know what I'm saying so it's it's just
it's just an honor to sit here and just
like dang you know I'm saying I'm
sitting with a piece of history right
now you know be phrasing man [ __ ] yeah
man that's amazing dude absolutely ain't
about money but
that's what it's about man and now and I
asked what I feel like that's what I
like the UFC man because I feel you know
out of it out of it all man I feel like
that that sport is it is bringing it
because you know people fight they fight
hard you know and they fight hard on
that man and you know this product that
I'm working on right now you know it's
with this company called onyx and you
know we changing the equipment game
because yeah this one X ESO so we
changing the equipment game we we in the
process of remaking the UFC glove
because you know we were trying to
adjust the eye pokes you know because at
the end of the day these athletes that
are in the UFC they're getting bigger
faster stronger and you got you know you
got guys like Johnny Walker you got guys
that's why they take them in the glove
yeah yeah that but you know what though
that was the only that has been the only
I guess improvement on combat equipment
and since the conception of equipment so
there's not been a lot of technology
that's been put into it and and that's
what that's what we do so great with
onyx because at onyx you know we were
you know Trevor Wittman is the brains
behind it this dude Trevor Wittman he
started making this equipment in his
basement and he would make the equipment
because he's the coach of like rows
number units and and just engage he and
here's the coach for myself in eight
Marquart and and when you see with this
new design in this club you're gonna be
like okay it's pretty dope because it
has such a new innovative look you know
that's awesome oh yeah so it's you know
I mean at the end of the day it's about
making sure that these athletes are able
to be safe enough to do what we able to
do because the training is the biggest
and hardest aspect of all of it and
here's the reality there's not a brand
new MMA gear yet because all the
equipment that we use is either borrowed
from Bobby's people get hurt in training
sparring and your thing yeah yeah they
do that's the hardest part that's why
I'm normally got it's just the dominant
spawn guys knocking out everybody who
hath me the some time guys the champ get
hurt because some kind of champs in
there with guys like a farm he could
beat anybody in the world yes can't beat
anybody in the ring right I was like oh
oh yeah Jimmy could beat anybody no
nothing compared the arrows this guy's a
bum you let this guy do this to you yes
yeah practice it's so funny interesting
you know that crosses over oh yeah oh
yeah I guess cuz guys feel more
comfortable when there's nothing at
stake
yes yo beat my ass in a Jim Dandy
fighting this bum is bum
destroying yeah I think when it comes
down to is we started this whole thing
off with just a mental aspect of
fighting like a lot of people can't
handle having and having a date like
like sometimes people they like the
violence fast right they can handle
somebody running up on about about we
throw in hands be I like the violence
fast but some people can't handle having
a day knowing that they're gonna have
somebody who's equally as matched with
is them facing them that's that's the
mind that's that's the mindfuck right
there that this makes people just it
just make us I'm not fighters you know
interesting you said that that's so in
tune because I'm at that aspect where
I'm the kind of guy I don't want to get
it's gone right now boom we're going
with frame I'm the kind of guy we wanted
I want to talk [ __ ] about anybody
yeah I like the action fast like I was
always one of those guys who always got
it started just when just oh man I was
crazy [ __ ] yeah man I mean it you know
we I mean I I was a wild boy growing up
man but it does that's why that's why
for me fighting saved my life man and
that's why that's why I'm you know I'm
involved with this progress this program
called always progress and you know what
we what we plan to do and what we've
been doing is we've been reaching out to
kids you know in in in rough communities
and kids who have you know problems and
stuff like that to be able to to show
them another way you know
saying and martial arts is one of those
things that I want to be able to give to
these kids and be able to show them
because fighting saved my life man if it
wasn't a fighting man I don't know man I
think I might be in prison so I've been
dead Oh lead to something but listen let
me give that back
if being involved will fighting that
would make me want to fight that I
wanted to be like those guys you see
these guys you want to be together got
nice clothes their car that beautiful
[ __ ] girl there all the holy [ __ ]
yeah Wow girlfriend she's awesome yeah I
drop dead beautiful oh I want some
awesome chick like that don't meet champ
of the world like that that was the
dream that was the fantasy yeah I have
big mansions and stuff airplanes and all
that stuff and then you get it and
you're like wait listen there's nothing
supposed to be not complete yeah
nothing's never as it appears to be
nothing you think the energies are left
ever but you gotta have a heart because
it'll be down moments you know yeah see
that's that's there that was Devils out
that was that's weird being rich and
seem like you're not happy you're not
excited I got all this money but none
happening you know fun what's happening
here good bunch of girls let's get a
donkey in this [ __ ] and make it
red yeah
yeah that's the quote of the day of the
day right there that is holy [ __ ] is
prayin Mike let's just go for it
Oh Mike you're a legend bro that's
brilliant man hold it don't know but
really right you think you take a guy
from where I come from Brownsville
Brooking with nothing but look like a
war zone drugs theft disease gangs
welfare addiction all over the place how
was I gonna make it alright and I'm in
the game of robbing and stealing all
that stuff how was I gonna make it I'm a
little guy I might know good athlete
anything you know he said has I probably
had 300 street fights right Wow as a kid
I had 300 Street Fighter 4 all they
played for fight the day something like
that everywhere your enable some of you
fighting somebody one day we listen one
day we pickpocket this lady on the bus
and we got the but we didn't think the
lady could know a complaint so we got
the wallet we got off the bus and next
thing you know we were walking up the
block we got the wild let me walk on the
block and next thing you know the lady
comes the block screaming and nothing we
were walking upon her house we just
walked by her house the guy said mommy
mommy that you're making us they start
running out we had to fight the narrow
let me you're gonna fighting for this
one
and the guys like a little kid and he
grabbed them you're the throne guys I
punched him and I grabbed a loom on the
snow how big we get eleven though how
big are like 175 pound
oh my god what you a hundred seven five
pounds at 11 years yeah oh you were God
that you are man yeah honey 75 oh my
gosh you were a man of God I got a
hundred seventy-five my friends seventy
pound eighty pounds I would that do the
violent hit the guy the guy I'm gonna
target yeah yeah I've I've been here
before I yeah been here before I got it
to some of that looked crazy there's a
strong man it yeah man we were crazy
growing up to man we did a lot of crazy
stuff man but you know you know one day
we caught a gutless one day too much oh
man one day somebody came in this room
and said yo yo listen this guy out there
he got some money got jury full of jury
we went after we got links to this guy
pulls out Bobby Rush to me good probably
the gun after we don't know yet it go
we rushed around whoa snap snap dude
boom slam on the floor he like he's down
we walked away leaves start shooting
boom hits my friend oh my god we don't
even know how to shoot boom everybody
gotta go
dang anybody gotta go that's crazy man
that's okay let it go did he make it
nah nah
damn that's that's that's nothing how
old were you in it when it happy was
around 15 though I was folly 12 oh wow
that's bananas what a tragedy
so like when that happened to how to
affect you did you like I got to change
everything
no I'm just kind of like I want to stay
the same day we still went Robin
when did you meet cus thirteen huh at 13
he meant Custer teen so a year later
yeah and then from then on did you stop
doing all the way no I used to go back
down every now and then and no no my
didn't Rob the guy listen right by then
I must eat cuz that give me around with
some stuff right so if the guys robbed
I'm right then the guys robbed so I said
listen I want to buy that coat and they
go rob the coat right no but I wouldn't
I wouldn't do it went get directly
involved you know me but I would bring
stolen goods to the house and stuff and
then I stopped I started winning
national titles and you started being in
the papers and I had to stop this [ __ ]
really stop one of my friends my other
friend got killed so I really was scared
your clothes like this I stopped yeah
what was the first fight you got paid
for fell old I got paid probably I'm
$0.50 a hotdog
what yeah when I was a kid I was like 14
for like your first fights and defied
the Spanish people used to pay the food
could be bet on its money that's deep
that's deep right there yeah that's so
crazy
so so you you saw so when so when did
you when did your style come out like
like what you had that that that
peekaboo style like that like when like
when did it come out when it was it was
the only under the costume did you or
did you cut well cuz never box you for
another play sports and nothing they
make cut okay okay okay you were just
raw what you want yeah I'm really raw
yeah that's deep man that's so awesome
training is training is training all the
time so it is very intriguing training
all the time because it's it's like you
know what what mike is experienced in
what mike has been able to be a part of
is is is is once-in-a-lifetime
yeah I'm saying I today even you know
sense even man it's like it's like
Hercules yeah I say it all the time yeah
it is Mike is our version of Greek
mythology not the way y know that's the
crazy thing dude it's all true
it's so awesome dude you probably been
through some crazy [ __ ] man crazy dude
I'll be damned
just imagine just oh I've been so
looking like listen um I'm in Miami yeah
what do you think about Miami is cray
that was a million some one thing boom
the kid who may pull I'm gonna pop out
they put diamond me know what you can oh
sorry champ I'll tell you that bitch-ass
[ __ ] somebody some football player man
oh man man man but that's respect right
there though man
why they pull the to leave chant we
taught you that [ __ ] ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think they rolled up on me to
see me piss on myself
[ __ ] Mike that's AB desam comp like
that's that's crazy bro that's so
intense what you or that bitch-ass [ __ ]
but Mike where's place where you feel
like you like alright when I go here I
gotta be careful because I always get us
some [ __ ] when I go here know that place
I'm a strip club or something yeah I'd
be cool when I put my tongue in the
[ __ ] mouth gram I got the [ __ ] man up
in a draw man
[Applause]
yeah yeah
[Applause]
keeps it real
Mikey a that's that's some real [ __ ]
right there that's a rush it's not [ __ ]
around
that's why Mike's a man that's why Mike
is it man oh listen I'm in I got in the
fight one day in the strip club and I
snuffed this guy right but me not me
being high not checking out my
surrounded he had his winners voice
enough man [ __ ] you buddy
so now you don't even [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what that's what it's about man
that's growth Mike because yeah it's
understanding what makes you weak you
know yeah yeah man we all got our
weaknesses I hear that bad mojo the
clubs in South Florida strip clubs in
South Florida it makes you want to save
them though it does it make you wanna
make it do man like I said girls yeah
man yeah I've seen some pretty strip I
don't want to devour them yeah yeah I
don't know I'm not trying to be no
chauvinistic Pig that's just my passion
baby's what a devour out and stuff I'm
too much of humanitarian you know I'm
saying I'd be like oh my gosh she's a
nice girl
at that time and it was nice I didn't
want I wanted a [ __ ] man yeah that's
what's up Mike see Mike Mike he lived
that you had a tall man that's that's a
beautiful thing man
yeah that's a beautiful thing man abhi
Mike see I I would love to have sort of
Mike Tyson experian
when I think when I gotta win the game
though that's not offending when I look
at a lot of guys I know girls they're
cooler with AIDS epidemic I caught it
with dope you know yeah that's that's a
theme and making sure you stay out all
that [ __ ] yes it's crazy dog that
you do there all those people that
thought got caught out there and smarter
than me I respect them and then telogen
the decision makings and they got thick
yeah without their dumb guy who I had no
respect my decision make it wander make
it that is just yeah stupid you know I'm
living my life the way I did
yeah man it's a blessing man I bet you
think that sometimes I dang how am I
even here huh I'm very grateful now yeah
well before I was young I wanted to kill
myself so bad but now as I get older I
want to live yeah you know a few things
you got look forward to see your
children and there's anyone look forward
to them growing and experiencing up your
experiences in life yeah absolutely
better absolutely man that's that's a
blessing right there man that's just uh
that's that realization man about that
that's that's where I'm at in my life
too you know where I'm starting to like
like get into that phase where um I'm
less about what I want to do it more
about what what the people I care about
want to do you know that's when it comes
down to the red my life now is all about
my family my kids yeah it worry you and
stuff my daughter's a little sick today
a little enlarged so we were worried
about her so we have to go check my wife
had just left a message that everything
is okay and it's just that um you know
you never know when that that moments
gonna calm yeah you know I mean when
you're vulnerable and it's nothing you
can do don't count much money you think
you got don't care how big a star you
think you're a bigger ego you think
you're somebody you love this suffering
you can't do nothing yes laid out like a
look like you're not just waiting yeah
then you go back to guard then you
realize that when you go to God when you
have nothing but your money to help you
your fate oh you turn into a little
[ __ ] puss and go oh god please help
me really go there yeah and that's and
that's it that's the thing about it like
it's you know honestly Bennett so so I
used to uh I said work in a hospital
when I was when I was coming up before I
was fighting the part of my job was to
put people into the morgue so I used to
see death all the time you know I'm
saying and I always used to put me in a
mental state where it was like man I
gotta make sure that I make this life
count you know I'm saying they put me an
appreciative mindset for life out the
gate man because like when you put them
bodies into the morgue in the back of
the body is still warm you don't say
that [ __ ] kind of stays in your mind for
a long time you know I'm telling because
it's it's you know somebody's life come
coming to an end you know it's kind of
some deep [ __ ] and it's kind of morbid
but I think a lot of people don't don't
think about you know the the totality of
how fragile life is enough you know one
little sunflower seed it with choke and
die off of yeah man very fragile he
seemed so indestructible you know you
see people seem to indestructible you
hear all Cenacle brain cancer yeah he
then destructed with this guys one and
two brick walls
he got brain cancer people right yeah
yeah and honestly speaking I think that
you know more than anything that we need
to be more conscious about you know what
is in our environment and to to make us
healthy because you know now we got you
know the 5g Network and all these 5g
towers out that's putting out these
these these broad bands and these
frequencies that's penetrating and going
through solid matter and clued in our
body yeah you know and pretty much you
know when you when you we think about it
you know our body appears to be physical
but at the same time it's nothing but
molecular yeah molecular frequency
slowing down at a different frequency
that's why I like when we do you know
any psychedelics they just change your
vibration then you vibrate it at a
different level you know what I'm saying
and then you vibrate out of your body
but you know those frequencies that are
in a 5g network you know those have you
know harmful part you know really bad
problems for our body in general you
really think about it like you think on
to think of
when I bodies been to the Fox radiation
doctor giving his medication or whatever
crazy [ __ ] he took over the year for
pain and I know man it's sin and all and
all that crazy stuff I used to have a
fentanyl patch on my box
cuz I used to have um bad hand so it's
not myself your foot box and get off it
just get off if I won't be detected in
the fight my hands hurt like lungs the
fighter I can deal with but I can't deal
with the constant punishment and
training but that that's but that was
that was like a like the breeze washed
our detox my body is just because I
wanted to just clean it out whatever all
the toxins and everything like that
because you know for a long time as an
athlete I did do a lot of those those
stuff like that so like when you say
that you're in a CBD market and you're
trying to do something for athletes to
make sure that they have something clean
to put in the body that helps to
replenish it and make sure that they're
able to compete and recover the nuts
that's all my life exactly because my
life was all about that fix yeah boom
that fix it boom that needle boom that
patch bloom that fix yet for that 45
minutes or whatever take them that's all
I need it for
you know I don't care the hand stuff my
foot was broken here in 45 minutes I
break it more you know you get and that
opens you up to opioid addiction and
that right there's nothing to play with
because once you play with that that
releases the monster that you just can't
control them then the addiction just
becomes so powerful that it just takes
over who you are as a person and and
that's and that's what we're and that's
the epidemic that we're facing right
here you know saying that all the all
the hard pharmaceuticals you know got
everybody addicted and then once they
start cutting back on it and everybody
started turning to the hard street drugs
the heroin drugs and you know you know
our country falling apart the United
yeah yeah we're pretty much a drug
feelin country
we're like China was in the thirties and
forties and twenties money opiate and
the British is the whole country with
the drug and country yeah opium terms
yeah yeah
yeah that's that's what we are now right
now yeah maybe but I'll kill your
big-time assistant president everybody
we're all getting high now yeah
hey we have a adjust but that's but see
that's that's why that's why I like
that's what I like you know with you
know the hot box in this show you know
why is it show so so important because
it what it does is it's it's putting a
different different spin or a different
kind of face on something that's been
still taboo for so long you know I'm
saying so many people look at you know
you know marijuana and CBD and things
like that nature they look at it with
such a different kind of you know
stereotype a negative stereotype but at
the end of the day you know when it
comes for me someone who suffered from
many concussions someone who's been you
know suffering from depression suffered
from you know CTE and all these things
that comes from the career that I chose
this is what gives me relief and in this
is real this is no commercial this is
what gives me relief this will make sure
so that I'm able to function this what
makes it so that I'm able to still speak
clearly you know and and I can't say
enough about it so like you know being
on how hot box on Mike Tyson you know it
is is more than just you know just just
being here with the champ man we sit in
a message about your career that's being
a fight at the Athina fighting you see
to get hurt real bad yeah I've seen a
lot of fighter if they got hurt real bad
you know you know uh you know and in
Bellator there's one situation where
this guy named cyborg got needing it
head
bye-bye Michael venom page and you know
dynamic 185-pound I caught him with a
knee and he and he actually put an
indentation in his head but you know
fortunately enough and here's a
beautiful thing about about the sport is
that no one has been like seriously
seriously injured but at the end of the
end of the day you know it's I mean it
may be just a matter of time but I think
that you know for some reason the
formula that we have in MMA has been
working that nobody's been getting
seriously hurt you know so you know it's
uh it's I guess I guess you know with
the
like that we can you know evenly
distribute the punishment of year of
attack evenly throughout the body you're
not just focusing on the on the waist up
you know you're not taking those heavy
heavy shots but I've seen some people
get get messed up like I one time I kick
to do in the head so bad and it was it
was it was so bad that like it took
forever for them to get him out it out
of the cage and it was one of those
moments where I was like man I think I
really I really really hurt to do it
because you know like if you put some my
lights out bad then they're never ever
the same after that the worst one the
one you know I know you're fighting you
know that when you hit somebody and it
felt like you missed them yeah dead yes
that's the clean you know that but you
feel like you miss yes he does yeah that
I don't know why's it that way all the
time yeah but man I had dogs through so
I had a Z feeling because I mean I mean
when I did it you you you you do it and
movement is happening so fast
you almost don't even feel like that you
even hurt and then you and then you
start to react to them like you're not
even knowing that they hurt and then it
just out of here you just like oh that
was a bad yeah that was a bad work you
know what yeah but you know back in the
day we were so crazy man we should do
this thing where we will come up behind
somebody and put them in what we call
the dope fiend
ain't no fear
don't faint and put him to sleep and we
do little school yeah was like I was
like trying to have to get caught sleep
the slipper man but yeah putting each
other sweet that's good because that's
what we did to the drunk I swim in the
pocket oh that's enough that's why
that's why I like kids these days man
like like there's a big epidemic I don't
know bullying but no bullying but here's
me record it like how do we how do we
confidently say no bullying no bullying
when we live in a society where we do
nothing but promote bullying yeah
everything everything that we promote is
as far as on a reality show that's
predicated on just that whole bullying
mentality so it seems you know rather
rather impossible or pretty impractical
to think that the children are gonna act
any other way than then what then what
there see you didn't saying but when we
were we were kids like bullies yeah one
day I had to fight this guy killed my
bird and I was scared to fight my friend
I wanted the fact I was mad about still
scared yeah but my friend said you Mike
[ __ ] fighter man yeah man we azzam I
didn't care if he [ __ ] me with okay
but see but see back in the day no you
you was willing to take an area bully
like I had a bully man my bully one of
my bullies was uh was one of my best
friend Craig his uh his uncle his name
was a uncle Billy and uncle Billy was
kind of a maniac Oh Billy black like
like here's uncle Billy like we'll go to
my voice we're gonna bout boys house
right and we'll go to his room and we'll
be in here now he shared a room with his
uncle and then his uncle get home from
school and he like hey what the [ __ ] are
you little [ __ ] doing in here
oh man we just we're just here to you
know wait for Craigie well guess what I
don't want you little [ __ ] in my room
and guess what that means that means I'm
gonna Lock this door and then I'm gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of every single every
single [ __ ] runner yeah really close
the door lock us in the door and he will
beat the hell out of us for like at
least two hours
are you three well he was a maniac bad
Billy but that's but that Billy was a
crazy son of a [ __ ] man he will be our
Aspen so that's the kind of bully that I
grew up with man but these kids don't
got buddies like that bad nobody
believed me unlike that they were
bullied a lot okay I'll turn your ass
right but see the thing is a lot of
these kids are like when they get
bullied online is that like a like
something that they did gets put online
like they get caught slipping somebody
taking embarrassing picture of them or
something like that and the nasan
element that's [ __ ] that's that's a
[ __ ] up that's the [ __ ] around
commit suicide yeah I mean [ __ ] up do
you feel like your life yeah when that
that happens man you feel like your life
is over is like a lot of these kids
can't handle it like never mind never
man that's that's the beauty of it man
just going through it and just and and
and just riding through that Valley man
you know that Valley will teach you
something yeah what are you doing these
days man yeah I got onyx you know I'm
you know also also working with this
fertilization company called fidelity
and we was trying to do some business
with Mike tell me about their whoo yeah
yeah so so what we have is we have like
an all-natural you know super friendly
fruit of the fertilizer that nice yeah
you can put on some marijuana and you in
it and it doesn't have any harmful
chemical chemicals it's so it's a little
safe that you can even like you can put
it on your hand you can spray it in your
mouth oh yeah yeah so is it something is
something that is
is a super super safe because no the
Atticus I mean there's a lot of catch
situations where you know um they had to
lose crops because you know if they get
caught with anything that has any kind
of bad chemicals pesticides in a metal
yeah heavy metal [ __ ] over I mean I
think I've been killer for you know long
listen be the beacon see guys our agent
you know I'm already you know how much
pesticide nobody home and yeah so much
so so yeah so on that man I have you
have you heard about the iodine
conspiracy yeah so yes so on that by me
yeah so uh so there so the problem is
the fact that the these these halogens
that's that's what these chemicals are
they getting the the bro the bromide and
all these the fluoride and all these
different chemicals that come onto our
our food and into our bodies
you know they compete for the same they
compete for the same I guess receptors
as iodine do and iodine is one of the
things that we actually need to have
cell development you know it's so
important to have an important if their
blood please no no no no I so so so
there there's iodine that you supposed
to take it is it's called a nascent
iodine you take nascent iodine and it's
super bio bio available for your body
because it would allow your body to
absorb it right away and most of us are
iodine deficient and most of the
problems that causes cancer is because
of a deficiency in iodine and that's and
that's something that that all this [ __ ]
in our water what the logs up the
receptors right would help us absorb
iodine right right so once you start
cleaning out your body and you start you
know supplemented with some like nascent
iodine and some other things that will
help to clean up your blood like you
know you need something for your stomach
like if you take there's a Nevada herb
called haritaki if you take something
like that that'll help clean out your
stomach and clean up your blood and it
also like adds like 300% more oxygen to
your brain so they were talking yes
called haritaki and you take it every
single night so
taken at night and if you you know you
you it what it is it's an astringent
powder that you take and it cleans out
your bowels it and when most disease
happens it happens because you know you
have food and stuff that doesn't can't
get processed through your body because
it gets it gets caked in there because
when we eat the foods that we eat it's
not bioavailable for our body so man
yeah yeah so it gets stored in areas
where it causes cancer what do we do to
break that down so that's what I'm
saying like that's that's what you do
you take stuff like haritaki that help
clean out your blood that'll help clean
out your digestive tract once you start
once you start doing stuff like that
taking iodine taking things to help
boost your iron don't fasten do that too
fast faster that's that but just go on
to a more electric diet going to more
you know fruits and vegetables and stuff
like that electric yeah because it's
because when when your body's too acidic
that's when you start to get all the
cancers that's when you get all these
things to grow but oh man I'm probably
[ __ ] no but even this even if you
start drinking something like distilled
water people say distilled water is not
good because it washes up the minerals
but that's not true washes up the
minerals that are not bioavailable to
your body so like night harmful minerals
that's what it washes off with all the
ones that all the ones that are good for
your body distilled water won't do it so
distilled water is something that
everyone can drink everyone can afford
you drink it and it just it cleans out
your body from a lot of the toxins that
we come in contact with interesting my
wife's got me on the celery juice every
more time you give the taste and I love
super it's electrically charged that's
the word yeah and in my mind when I'm
drinking this man and you drink it first
thing in the morning it's supposed to
just clear out all the [ __ ] out of your
livers and stuff yes hope you go to the
bathroom yes and that's not anything
good [ __ ] was just interesting to hear
you say like electric foods because this
is the first time I've ever had
something I was like this is like
electrically charged yeah this drink yes
anyway I love it man I'm a big dude
you're like you're the [ __ ] man
I'm trying to show you Sean here the
nobodies Sean and your shovin Mike I am
working in that direction yeah Mike
coming up to you years ago and being
like I saw your fight you're in your
heart and that whole fact that was that
was that was one of the biggest moments
of my life man it was just like cuz cuz
I looked up to Mike for so long and to
have him come up and talk to me and said
he seen me fight I was like I was
brought to just tears but you know Mike
gave me some good advice man he told me
he actually told me some things that
that I didn't listen to an independent
price for you know he gave me some
advice about being a being in a marriage
and being and stuff like that and I
didn't listen and I end up getting a
divorce
but I never fail yeah yeah yeah yeah
Mike but Mike Mike was advice it was
something all the lines about like you
know he knew how big of a supporter my
ex-wife was and stuff like that and he
talked about you know just about making
mistakes and things like that because I
think he was that healed at the point in
his life where he was starting to you
know starting to understand different
things so wake up yeah yes so so he so
he was kicking game and I was like I was
really surprised man because you know
it's a cold feeling when you're alone
though and feelings : your loan you
don't have [ __ ] you've broken the money
alone no friend what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do and I said that's that's a that's a
very that's a hard feeling man that's a
hard feeling man I had you know I had a
situation where I had you know a manager
take some serious money from me and you
know that that that is a hurtful thing
because you know as it you know I didn't
I didn't make all the millions and
millions of dollars like as a fighter so
I am a fighter when you lose some money
man that that money that money hurts me
you know I'm saying so you know it can
bring you to a dark place man but it's
just you know as a fighter that dog put
mr. hamund beat some Portland promoters
up so bad oh man I do this guy
man man I am such a he's pretty God
forgives me one day you know see my
maker
I was just wired this guy stole
something that this understand about the
winner doom - when I've got hold of a
man's crazy yeah it was crazy fighting
this fight is crazy I thought I thought
I thought my mind I was a [ __ ] god of
war how dare you disrespect me a violent
I had my mom that sick Wow I thought
Nicky you out of here my man I thought I
was somebody was supposed to do that - I
was so caught up in that mindset yeah
when was it was a moment where you had
to confront Mike Tyson the fighter
versus Mike Tyson you know the person
like cuz because there's always that
moment where it's that like where you
have to kind of you know put make a
division between the two of them what
did that happen tonight one of my
daughter died for your daughter that
passed away and there was nothing I can
do [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah that's a
heartbreaking thing yeah that's that's
see that's just a part of life like you
know when you when you just want to you
know you just want to just just like tap
out and and then but then you find in
some way to just for some reason to keep
on going back and now I'm [ __ ] I think
that happened and I was I had no money I
was busted and a friend of my put
$50,000 for the funeral wow that's
amazing for him that's what the sauce
was up you know yeah I don't even ask
somebody thought it happened in a baby
with boom yeah that's that's love right
there man
see that's that's what it's about man
having having people like that and
that's why that's why I have so much
respect man for for you my friends will
help me but they would never give me no
money they'd help me out but even if I
needed something by somebody never give
me no money ain't no I would put that
somewhere that wouldn't feel good at you
know yeah so like after after all that
that's the moment where you started
turning around that's me yeah guitar
start to to rebuild I wanted to change
my life for her yes that's the blessing
in life and sometimes that's what that
becomes a hard part about when we
suffered through tragedy you didn't say
it's hard to see that the impact of a
life like the movie like collateral
Beauty there's always a collateral
beauty and so much things in life and it
comes on the backs of those those hard
those hard those hard situations right
it was weird because I was still OD I
was getting high I was old Dean man I
was getting [ __ ] up and my wife said
two more we will change our life and
stop doing this we're gonna get some
shows and start writing shows and doing
it and the next time no um we she wrote
a show from when I started doing this
one man a show you know yeah
then it was on from then on everything
started going up and that's the beauty
because that became that became your
therapy that became me rehab that became
big time yeah that's dope once you
experience the toe you did you have do
you have a different perspective on that
situation
on the on the passing of your daughter
well I'm different perspective on the
way I look at people and the way I talk
to people I don't never look at them the
same
you know I know everything that
everything I know most of us is just ego
fed and we're afraid to show who we
truly are
yeah we feel naked without my ego ego
give us a false sense of security
absolutely have you ever tried have you
ever tried mushrooms
oh yeah Adam awesome but they had a bag
is bad experience because I'm in there I
got mushrooms and then I got my mom I'm
on mushroom I got my prostitute
girlfriend then I got guys trying then I
got guys trying to hit on my girlfriend
when I wanted a mushroom and so I get
mad to mushrooms so I get um [ __ ]
golf club me I start going ill in the
house yeah yeah he's got gonna Elka
trespass we're gonna go on a hoot
last week we had Joey Diaz on yeah he
talked about doing acid in prison I was
like I was in prison I was scared -
handle that [ __ ] man no [ __ ] way
oh my what was the craziest part about
being at prison just from G I mean just
from I mean you know you incarcerated in
there I mean the survival is just a
different mentality getting up saying
like how did how did you make that
adjustment man prisons like prisons the
closest thing to being dead you know you
locked up away from the world you have
no connection with the world at all you
know yeah and no connection can't no you
can't touch nobody behind the glass and
only that that's the only time the dead
in the [ __ ] life I'm communicators
when somebody's in prison he's really
dead - leaves back out she may never
come out yeah you know and you have to
accept that reality you know I mean that
reality that you don't exist but you do
but you don't you know you do but you
don't see that's the hardest part is
probably just seeing everybody just fall
away from you and then at the same time
you know you just kind of like in a
place where
you got me like you said you feel dead
only they know people are dying her
loved ones are hurt you can't do
anything for them
normally that you could help them you
can't help them and then then forget
that that's what that's your personal
get you got to deal with now you gotta
deal with these idiots in here right now
you gotta deal with the idiot oh I mean
you had to have people try on you until
you'd be had to be like yellow I'm not
just oh no society no listen no no I got
an altercation with this guy right and I
got in this altercation with this guy
and I finally this guy the game when
this guy get 600 guys sitting on the
guys outside right and but I'm playing
off like I'm a scared of nothing right
I'm playing nothing left I'm playing it
up inside I'm dying eyes all should
these [ __ ] were gonna kill me right
and then I move at the core and then
somebody see your mic man they got a
couple hundred [ __ ] out there waiting
you come out right you know this uh
mother got this little guy little black
ponytail guys he said this well Mike got
friends too
he got around a thousand guys I said
whoa I said listen I don't want no
trouble nice kick us out on the trip and
I'm just squash this stuff and I got in
deep right you know I mean that's what I
that's the first time I really
experienced real gang activity hey you
know bro and so I said lazy [ __ ]
squash step up and shake his hand and
make yeah it's a pair to be cool really
able to do that yeah then it was cool
but they didn't wanted to squat they
have some really personal stuff that I
don't want them to use me for that stuff
right there to [ __ ] me away it put me
somewhere I didn't want to leave that
prison
you know that must have been incredible
for you for this guy in that prison to
be the guy to just bring peace for that
situation
holy it was crazy it was crazy and the
guys came out knows the mic got friends
who have no way thank you
I know that guy I know where Michael
Mike got friends to his luck [ __ ]
yeah let's see buddy yeah so that's what
I'm saying I would say that's that's the
mentality part man that that is is is
about you just being a survivor man you
know I'm saying from day one is being
able to always make that transition
transition make that adaptation to
whatever the life present you man
actually always fed that reputation is
the number one survival method be able
to adapt to situations yeah I wish they
can print out always the cool guy after
that I would make sure if I got the
drugs and everything I learn no trouble
and chill out so I buy a bunch of drugs
hey yo chill no Trouble Man cuz they had
a joke sometimes yes I was like a good
strategist yeah it's a great strategy
know how to be diplomatically yeah see a
smart man I'm smart and I learned not to
get into arguments with the gods of the
guy see I'm Tyson and you put some money
in my books off [ __ ] his world up like
that didn't care they had a number time
yeah you put money in that book to get
anything done over there
but that's crazy because you would think
though that they would have you just
like in in isolation are like you would
think they did something is the middle
place in the world we locked down 23
hours a day and you think they let you
outside to go work out for you know they
put a cage right to yourself okay come
on
yeah that's insane that's insane
see man there's so much there's so much
power in Mike story managers just from
just all the different phases and all
the different mindsets that one must has
to encompass you know just just even
survive man it's crazy it's anybody so
sorry sympathetic for mean you got [ __ ]
every was sympathetic for me there isn't
like I got was a sad puppy they wouldn't
believe he's some super bad living man
[ __ ] yeah this is funny to them is [ __ ]
we got to like dad yeah yeah did they
change the law to get you yeah that's
that [ __ ] man
suppose so and it's all about that
rebound baby yeah absolutely
everybody so much time had babies try to
give me in programs and stuff I can get
my kind cut and everything's no go to
this program wait time you cut in half
we wanted to know you do too you do this
you do that cut this is the law library
cut that cut disc on this program but
you so you had to learn a lot and you
had to learn a lot in there just to make
sure you like I mean you had to learn
like that's probably had to be the spot
where you yeah but little was knowledge
tape game this is the problem this
program when I first came in printing I
was so irate I'm at will fighting with
the cars worth of always had
altercations with the God and over the
time by the time I started cooling out
me into God's a friend all those fights
they build up so I had to come back to
have to give me extra year so I had to
go to all these programs to cut the year
or three I've been do for cycle all
these programs okay okay that's crazy
man that's well if you're gonna situate
the stairs trouble don't get into
arguments with nobody cuz the pin that's
more powerful than the sward in there
they start writing you up man yeah what
I'm on top of time they hit you listen
yeah you get like you're going there for
three years to come back and wanna get
life in there many occasion I feel guys
came in and they got three four years
when I'm getting like just you know just
trying to survive it it's got caught up
the support them from
[ __ ] and I mean stabbing people all
that crap stuff yeah many stories you
hear you know yes yes that's crazy man a
person's gotta be just a different
mindset altogether no you think you know
what's gonna happen to you when you get
in there you know somebody's gonna kill
you or your little charge you know
what's gonna happen oh you might kill
somebody
yeah you know anybody danger everybody
the little skinny white boobs the long
hair they're all dangerous in there
they're all very dangerous and it's
gotta be crazy because you have a target
on your back yeah who you are and
everything like that so all dangerous I
never listen let me tell you something
about me I am I was a kind of fighter I
was so afraid I wanted everybody to be
afraid of me you know I mean that was me
I'm showing my fear my ferociousness and
all that that was my fears right you
know people always took that this is the
absence of savage guidance to feel but
that was all my fear that's all
fear-based that God I created a savage
guy you know you know he's scared of
everybody
yeah base and less low self-esteem and
stuff but I had to make my mania ego you
know yeah yeah yeah
but he always had this great vocabulary
man which you read your dictionary all
time growing up away no listen right
how'd you get this little cabaret my
perfect my mentor you still helped me go
will go over words and stuff you just
show me the words write them down with
the AIDS and be them used to go over
words especially when it came to combat
sports and I used to read about the old
fighters in how guys would say this guy
to a lightning bolt like Thor at the
floor like Achilles and he's the gate to
write about these guys like god I wasn't
right about me like that you know
I love that yeah so man anything I don't
know what Magdalena was and that was
just a pride to be a fighter to be a
feather if it please you forgive me if
I'm a savage back like a fat because
really I am because I am a savage
something that's powerful - brilliant -
because it's true is true age it's true
man because you have to be a savage no
because the fact is because I'm say you
of that way was really taboo you know I
mean the real like self derogation and
today everybody had big egos and the one
same great and successful
[ __ ] savage or a beast tell me but I
took that honor and I'm ready to inflict
that on people - the sugar one which I
salvaged that's all I was into a
fighting endless warfare and
psychological warfare and everything
about fighting and woman it's always
read about fighting and combat a
fighting how guys won fights without
even fighting you know yeah and that's
the art of fighting to win fights
without fighting right and that's what
you do the best you had a lot of people
be before the fight even started oh
absolutely because when I was such
afraid but I thought it realized these
guys are more afraid of me than I am
with them yeah you know yeah I remember
seeing the the Olympic where you know
nothing like what you're doing the thick
you compete in a tournament and you're
crying before the fight you know you're
crying before just just just being
giving in to your nerves and get the -
yeah yeah yeah yeah but now that was
that was a powerful moment man what that
was
that was one of those thing when the
time comes click go away yeah yeah yeah
get it did it that was one of those
things man I just helped me to be like
man it's okay to to be able to have
these feelings because this is how you
handle these
you know yeah some people different some
people um some people before faith in
the mirror getting beautiful like
they're going out on a date before the
fight no and everything everything
looking good these guys would be putting
[ __ ] gel in their hair are you doing
I'm like spitting and [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the fact that's a war psychology too
you know I read about the Greek warfare
Alexander the Great is always going to
battlefield smelling beautiful looking
beautiful you know I'm a always ready
for war yeah yeah I mean I think I think
maybe you know for me I used to always
get dressed up before I would compete
like you know I think that we're gonna
put on suits and how to come up yeah but
that that was one of the process that
that helped me to alleviate some of my
nerves and from from me thinking about
the fight because if I had a routine
that I was doing then I was focused on
my routine and not worried about you
know aspects of the fight or how I'm
gonna feel and I used to do that too
when I stuff for the face in the press
conference and then I started thinking I
have to be the person I am so [ __ ]
lucky can't matter than me
yeah yeah right I mean if I'm gonna
savage this stuff can't matter to me
that's why you never came out with a
robe yeah stuff commanded me how do you
be a savvy luxury matters to you yeah
that's true that's true that's a
different business so deep Mike that is
the that but that's deep though because
that explains why he will come out with
just a towel yeah no socks and just
relax shoes and black shorts you don't
say that's that was a joint that'll keep
that image I did I wrote that fabric I
wanted to keep them
comfortable I want to keep them afraid
because I was afraid yeah I want them to
feel what I was feeling
yeah I wanted to feel the heart bubble
in that blood bubbling and they [ __ ]
on themselves go to the bathroom every
five minutes I want me to fear that -
yeah talk about fighting and suppose
you're talking about emotions yeah
stuff that we do this is not what people
do actually do for they don't do for no
nice what we do for a living people
avoid the whole life confrontation they
avoid that they'll like me we do for a
living so that's that then we're in a
different mind scheduler than most
people yeah yeah different mindset
there's no doubt about it thanks much
those dope as hell bro yeah my thanks
but I'll for you I appreciate you having
me oh man yeah the toad Megan listen
most brothers afraid of stuff like bang
right man you know brother so whether
you talk about that white boys [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] right that's what I
do when it hit me boom I said oh sure
[ __ ] up them white boys they got me
let me ask you this were you able to
think in that place were you able to
have any thought why he was there then
no boom it's got hey I started seeing
[ __ ] Mike I could talk to myself I hear
myself talk in my head but man I was out
cold yeah I couldn't move and I started
seeing those pyramids and all that Aztec
seeing stuff yeah and the demand it's
made out of razor stuffing man it was
crazy they say so there's a book called
Tibetan Book of the Dead and it is it
speaks about how do you die right and
they speak on the stage of death that
pretty much describes what happened when
you do the toad it's called it's like
the first stage of Bardo the Bardo means
in between so in the first stage is that
you are engulfed in this everlasting
encompassing light and you feel the
other you feel the feel of the all like
you feel how you feel when you do the
toad and you're supposed to recognize
that that's you but a lot of people they
say they say that when you pass through
and death that is so seamless and so
smooth
that you don't even know you died so
most people don't know they died so when
they feel that feeling they run from
that feeling and then they go back into
a reality that that fits their their
emotional state the fact I'm run from it
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what holes
but but what it is is it's it's the ego
death though that's what it is is that
ego death and and what we have to
realize is that that is the essence of
death that is the extent of death is the
fact that the ego is going to die the
I'd the idea of who you think you are in
this flesh and bone is is going to die
and that's the scary part but that's not
the end of existence yes but that's what
you think we listen only thing I had
that's all I had was my ego my egos all
I had this all that made me made me
believe that I was who I wasn't yeah you
know my ego was the only thing that
could do me told me things I could do
that I never dreamed that I can do you
know me but it told me lies - yeah you
know told me lies I mean I try to live
up to life that we're unexist abou we
can be challenged to touch the tangible
yeah you know yeah so interesting there
you go they say it's the thing that ties
our spirit to our physical body yeah
really yeah that's why that's why that's
why here's what we all need to do we
need to go on a adventure where we do
some some I mean treat mushrooms Oh
retreat and do some mushrooms in nature
man I'm telling you let's do it that's
some healing stuff man they actually
gonna legalize they're gonna legalize
psilocybin and or and also in they're
also trying to do the same thing in
Colorado so you know psilocybin is
healing a lot of people they say yeah
they say they say this how powerful
psilocybin is psilocybin is so powerful
that one dose one good dose of
psilocybin is worth six months of
depression free symptoms wait can we try
it what can we try it oh well you you I
mean there's place you can get so
solvent it'll be interesting to see how
that gets like worked out well I mean
there are they talking
or yeah whether I think this I think
they're talking about medicinal I think
that you know they're also trying to
maybe line up a study with with with
John Hopkins and things that really put
some real research behind psilocybin s
facts India psilocybin is a name for
mushrooms but is it is is one of those
it's one of those things that that it
helps you heal on another level because
when you do psilocybin you you learn to
confront the problems yourself so
there's a lot of things about about each
of us that it gets really hard to face
when you're in this reality but once you
do psilocybin it shifts your ego enough
were you able to have a perspective and
perspective is all you need is to have
understanding right so once you have
that understanding that becomes your new
truth and then based off that new truth
whatever you feeling becomes dissipated
were you able to have a different
understanding because I mean that's
that's the power of the medicine you
know so [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean that that's what that's what
a good session of doing the medicine can
do it can really shift your mental state
and have you and have you seen life in a
different perspective that that that is
is is in cohesiveness with with with
existence in general yeah just with the
the the the non [ __ ] of life because
once your ego is removed you get to see
that there's not much difference between
you and I know absolutely what you eagle
remove you realize that you know you
think you're not a savage right yes
frightening little boy right you know I
mean yes not as have your friend boy
yeah I need somebody to hug you baby
love you
absolutely to trust you everybody thank
you for listening to this episode of
hotboxing I'm Evan Britton I'm Mike
Tyson and I'm Rashad Evans [ __ ]
Thank You Rashad thank you out of here
yeah
please away we have food here dude that
was literally the best podcast thank you
[Music]